bild krieger
[Musik]
willkommen zurück hierbei bild live und
wir beginnen mit einem aktivisten
überfall in wilhelmshaven etwa 300
mitglieder der protest organisation ende
gelände stürmten und besetzten den
import terminal für flüssiggas lng er
sie schaffen es sicher auf dem gelände
zu verteilen rohre und bagger dort zu
besetzen die aktion die wende sich gegen
den geplanten ausbau fossiler gas
infrastruktur das sagen die aktivisten
seit bekanntwerden der lng pläne
kritisieren umweltorganisationen den
flüssiggas terminal sie verlangen ein
ende der nutzung von fossilen
brennstoffen dass die unangemeldete
aktion jetzt ausgerechnet heute
stattfindet ist tatsächlich kein zufall
denn niedersachsens ministerpräsident
stephan weil von der spd wird heute auf
eben dieser baustelle erwartet sprechen
wir darüber mit unserem reporter gerd
schröder er ist vor ort gerritsen jetzt
aktuell die lage wir sehen relativ viel
polizei im hintergrund
ja hier am jadeweserport ist erstmal
ende im gelände sowie auch die
aktivistengruppe hier heißt die hier die
blockade durchgeführt hat sie sind
offenbar mit reisebussen vorgefahren
fünf reisebusse 60 personen sind sehr
adhoc hier in einer großen mannstärke
aufs gelände gestürmt und haben hier die
baustellen lagerfläche blockiert das
heißt hintergrund sehen wir als die
lagerfläche wo die pipeline rohre liegen
die pipeline rohre die hier verarbeitet
werden sollen um das neue lg terminal
irgendwann an das fernwärmenetz
anzuschließen und genau hier haben die
aktivisten die baustelle blockiert sie
sind in rohre geklettert haben sich in
rohren festgekettet sind auf radlader
gestiegen und das ganze ist noch sehr
unübersichtlich weil die aktivisten
nicht nur hier am jadeweserport sondern
auch in hooksiel auf der anderen seite
der baustelle wohl auch eine größere
lokale durchgeführt haben so dass die
polizei erstmal sich ein bild
verschaffen muss wo ist eigentlich
gerade was los ein hubschrauber kreist
über der szenerie und versucht sich ein
bild zu machen es kommt immer weitere
mannschaftstransportwagen der polizei
hier an
im endeffekt nachher diese blockade
irgendwann lösen zu können wobei bei der
großen man stärker an aktivisten wird es
eine sehr sehr aufwendige einsatz um
diese ganzen personen hier wieder aus
der baustelle herauszubekommen also das
kann noch etwas dauern die polizei dort
immer ein satz wie bewertest du die lage
jetzt wird es noch dauern das alles
aufzulösen wenn wir werdens kartei
gerade angesprochen die politik gleich
um vor ort ministerpräsident dort gleich
vor ort das muss ja irgendwie möglich
sein dort diesen besucher abzuwickeln
oder glaubst du dass es den aktivisten
gelingt diesen besuch vielleicht gar zu
verhindern
der besuch soll verlegt worden sein dass
er vom marinestützpunkt hier ablegt mit
einem schiff der ministerpräsident
stephan weil von dort aus kann er auf
sicherem weg sozusagen von außen sich
ein bild machen von der baustelle hier
direkt vor der küste in der nordsee wo
das lng terminal entsteht das heißt der
ministerpräsident wird umgeleitet an den
aktivisten vorbei und hier diese
blockade das wird sich aber ein bisschen
hinziehen bis das alles gelöst wird wie
gesagt 300 aktivisten an verschiedenen
orten festgekettet und um das zu lösen
bedingt ist einfach jetzt unheimlich
viel polizeikräften die ja diese einzeln
aktivisten herausführen müssen
personalien feststellen müssen usw und
die kräfte ziehen sich hier immer weiter
zusammen zunächst will natürlich erstmal
auch um versorgung sich gekommen hat es
werden vier getränkekisten reingeholt es
ist hier brütend heiß strahlende sonne
32 grad im schatten und dort ist kein
schatten dort ist einfach platt ist
bauland und das wird also noch sehr sehr
lange dauern bis die baustelle wieder
vernünftig arbeiten kann und das bleibt
abzuwarten was die polizei ist hier
genau macht der tour ist das ganze
natürlich weiterhin für uns beobachten
und natürlich auch diesen besuch von
stephan weil warten ab ob sich die
aktivisten da nicht auch auf dem seeweg
irgendwas ausgedacht haben dankeschön
gilt für den moment
[Musik]